all right today's question comes from
nicholas in new york
nicholas asks how do i say no to friends
and family
that want to go out and do things that
just do not fit in my budget
i'm currently on baby step two and i'm
doing the debt snowball and my budget is
very tight
i just always feel terrible saying no to
my friends and i'm afraid to lose them
any thoughts i think you're under 40.
yeah i think so i was gonna say i think
so um
nicholas i'm just gonna call out the
elephant in the room here
if your friends don't want to hang out
with you
then you need to get some other friends
they're not friends they're not your
friends
friends that you have to pay for is
called prostitution that's i wasn't
gonna go there but dave did so yes
nicholas these aren't your friends so to
put it in perspective
um when me and my friends this is just
five six seven years ago
we got together and we were all trying
to
tighten up things financially and so we
had fun at the house
bringing leftovers over and you know
there would be quarter bottle one and a
half two liter bottle of diet coke and a
half eaten casserole and we didn't care
we called it rotisserie we just rotated
friend's house
here's the deal we made it work why
those are my closest friends in the
world
and friends who say oh you have a goal
you're trying to better your life and we
don't want you around
then sucks to be you man we're going out
without you are sending you
very clear signals that they're not your
friend so how do you say no
i hate to tell you this but you say no
and then you have to do the hard work of
trying to find some other friends man
yeah if
um your friendship is based on the
activity of hanging out
it is not a real friendship right and so
you've got some work to do on
how to build actual friends yeah um
because you you know i feel
terrible saying no to my friends at 60
years old
also but not for those reasons it's a
friend of mine you know has something
going on and i really should be there
but i can't because i've got something
else
right i can't be present but it's not uh
uh
and so i feel bad if i can't be there uh
one of my friends mom passed away i
couldn't get to the funeral
you know i was in the middle of
something else i couldn't go
and i felt terrible for that but that
that's a different kind of a thing then
i don't have the money to go spend money
because the only way my friends want to
hang out with me is when we're spending
money at some club
in an example in my life very similar is
i had a buddy called the other day
with a great real estate opportunity say
hey me
and another friend of ours we're getting
in on this we want you to pitch in
and it wasn't a part of my plan for 2021
or 2022
and i'd said or ever well i mean i
wouldn't mind
but but here's the thing i told them
i can't be in on this one and he said
well you're an idiot and then we talked
about our kids
right he's still my close friend right
and so that's the difference between
is he gonna love you plus your values
not um
walk away from you yeah that sucks man
yeah
there's a uh reading your sentence
structure
and the way you went at the question
tells me that there's a shallowness
to uh your connectivity to these people
you call friends
yep and so let's deepen the connectivity
so let's get a few of them that are real
friends
and fewer hangers on there you yeah